الى ديار بكر مع وليد العطار
ووليد ايضا حيث انت كيف تتباين النتائج ما
بين التصويت للرئاسه وكذلك التصويت
للبرلمان مع يعني اختتام الفرز في ديار
بكر
نعم محمد بالفعل اختتم يعني اكتملت فرز كل
الصناديق في ديار بكر والبالغ عددها اكثر
من 3600 صندوق
وكانت نسب المشاركه سواء في الرئاسه او في
البرلمان وفق النتائج الاوليه
اكثر من واحد وثمانين في المئه فاصله سبعه
وهي نسبه عاليه بلا شك نتحدث هنا عن ولايه
ديار بكر التي دعي للانتخاب فيها مليون
ومئه
وثلاثه واربعين الفا واكثر من اعترابه
بليونو 144,000 من سكان ديرب من الداخلين
في ديار بكر التباين كان شديدا وكان لافتا
في بين يعني مؤشرات او ما اسفرت عنه
الرئاسيات وما اسفرت عنه البرلمانيات
مرشح المعارضه كمالك الاجدار اوغلو
المتقدم بنحو اثنين وسبعين في المئه
اي ما معدله اكثر من 6000 و1 اكثر من 600
و51 الف صوت في مقابل
26%
وبعض الاعشاء الكسور العشريه للرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان وهي مسافه بعيده نتحدث عن 72
مقابل 26 معدل الاصوات او عدد الاصوات نحو
ثلاثه
ثلاثمائه وتسعه وثلاثين الف صوت تقريبا
للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان هذا التباين
يشير الى ان
الدعوه التي دعاها او دعا اليها او
التاييد العلني الذي اعلنه صلاح الدين
رئيس حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي رغم انه همم
سجين لمرشح المعارضه قبل الانتخابات قد
اتت اكلها وهي اتت اكلها لان صلاح الدين
ضاع الى ذلك ونحن نقول هذا بالنظر الى
التباين الكبير بين نتيجه كمالك في
الرئاسيات 72 في المئه وبين نتيجه تحالفه
تحالف الشعب في البرلمانيات وايضا نتحدث
عن مؤشرات اوليه حتى يعلنها المجلس الاعلى
للانتخابات حيث لم يتمكن من تجاوز عتبه
العشره في المئه يعني هو حصل على
بل تجاوزها وفقا لاخر المؤشرات ربما عشره
ونصف او عشره واثنين من عشره في المئه
وهذا وهذا تباين كبير لان المتقدم في
البرلمانيات هو التحالف الذي به او الذي
يتزعمه حزب اليسار الاخضر
الواجهه السياسيه التي خاضت الانتخابات
نيابه عن حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي نظرا لما
يتعرض له من اشكالات القضيه هنا ايضا محمد
ان
الناخب الكردي
بسبب الولاءات السياسيه وبسبب ايضا ضغوط
المعيشه ونسب البطاله واشواق التغيير التي
تحدث عنها معنا خلال الايام السابقه عدد
من الناخبين الناخب الكردي لم ينظر كثيرا
لما حققه حزب العداله والتنميه للمره
الاولى في تاريخ الجمهوريه التركيه الذي
اتم قرنا هذا العام عندما اقترب منذ عقد
من حلحله الازمه الكرديه والمواجهات
المسلحه التي استمرت عقودا بين الدوله
وبين مسلحين اكراد حيث تمكن لاول مره
تمكنت حكومه العداله والتنميه من بدء
عمليه سلام وكانت تمشي في خطوات
يعني ملموسه حتى انتكست بعدها بعامين فضلا
عما منح
للمكون للكردي من يعني حقوق وامتيازات كان
يعني يرجوها وخاصه على الصعيد الثقافي
الصغير الصعيد الاعتراف بلغته على تدريس
لغته هذه الامور لم تحدث قبل عهد العداله
والتنميه ولكنها لم ترجح كفه حزب العداله
والتنميه في هذه الانتخابات او تحالف
الجمهور الذي يتزعمه حزب العداله والتنميه
هذه النتائج صحيحه انها اوليه ولكنها لاقت
ارتياحا من شريحه من الشباب ممن لقيناهم
بالامس قرب المجلس الاعلى للانتخبات
المتجمعين حول يعني ساعات الصباح الاولى